watch out AOC there's an even woker
member of Congress that's trying to hog
the spotlight with stupid stunts and I'm
not talking about far Marshall Bowman
say hello to jenz Congressman Maxwell
Frost in an attempt to stick it to the
racist Republicans who believe in
borders little Maxi is suggesting that
the GOP wants to get rid of the Statue
of Liberty don't welcome immigrants if
you plan to reject them if you keep
pushing your bigoted hr2 bill then also
pass this bill I've taken the liberty of
drafting it for you it removes the
Statue of Liberty our largest symbol
that tells people to come here this is
who you are removing the fabric of
America sorry Max Lady Liberty ain't
going anywhere and the American people
completely disagree with Democrats open
borders Insanity I'll let Charlemagne
explain why I honestly have never spoken
to as many people who are concerned
about the migrant issue issue as I have
you know o over the past year people
were calling the radio station that was
just this week you know really really
really complaining about that so I've
never seen you know workingclass people
who I interact with every day until this
past year really really really Express
their frustration for the migrants all
right Greg what do you think of little
Maxi's stunt how stupid is this clown uh
excuse me maxi pad we we don't take down
statues
you take down statues taking down
statues is the only form of aerobic
exercise the woke cretans have without
pulling down a statue they wouldn't have
any upper body strength the woke workout
is three sets of looting three sets of
burning followed by the statue pull and
toss so shut up Charlamagne however
stumbled into reality unfettered illegal
immigration hurts minorities in the
working classes by drastically lowering
wages uh here in New York you could see
this the almost all delivery jobs I've
seen from from new arrivals I would like
to get charlamagne's address and send
him a few copies of Thomas Soul's books
which explains incentives and
disincentives and how cheap labor uh and
the and illegal immigration that causes
cheap labor creates uh uh a a job loss
among minorities this's another example
of how the left hurts the people they
claim to help do you when you send
Charlamagne a package have to write the
God on the envelope I don't know about
that that's a good question it's more
likely to get there right that's true
Dana well I think that this sort of
talks this connects well with our first
block because I believe immigration is
the canary and the coal M for all of Joe
Biden's ills in the ABC poll that came
out over the weekend he was at 18%
approval on immigration and so that was
like Max Frost and his buddies that he
goes to brunch with on Sundays and you
know he goes to brunch um and Biden is
doing nothing about itch right I hate
brunch um Biden is doing nothing about
changing the the Border policies he's
suing Texas he's he's blaming Texas
National Guardsmen for murder and then
when proven wrong they won't take it
back and he won't take the Republicans
up on their offer to get money for
Ukraine and money for Israel that Biden
wants what they're asking for is tougher
border enforcement maybe they're not
going to be able to swallow all of it
but why not take the Republicans up on
their offer and if the Republicans vote
it down run on that and say I tried and
if they take you up on it take credit
for the fact that you were able to stem
the flow before the election and why
would he want to do that I want to point
out something that it's not just Biden's
job approval numbers that are going down
and this is why you're starting to see a
lot of agitation including from people
like uh Jamie Diamond of JP Morgan all
these polls are starting to come in for
house Democrats especially ones in kind
of districts where you might be able to
get a republican through and their
numbers are way down so Biden is
dragging down the entire ticket whereas
Trump would be able to improve that
maybe even keep the house for the
Republicans pero do you hate brunch and
what do you think of Maxi I don't like
brunch and I don't like Maxi is that all
is that all I have to say I just want to
say something about the Statue of
Liberty the Statue of Liberty was a gift
from France that came here in 1886 at
that time we had an immigration law in
this country where you came here you had
to be on Ellis Island you had to be
screened and you had to be documented
you had to be tested uh that you had to
be vaccinated and you could only come in
if you had a sponsor or if you were
self-reliant okay this guy doesn't know
his history and you know the truth is if
you understood the background of of the
Statue of Liberty it's a symbol of
freedom and democracy it doesn't mean
everybody just show up and we'll take
care of you and that's why Joe Biden I
believe is going to lose the election
Assuming he's the guy that runs um what
is happening to the Democrats now is
that they are now it's not just the top
tier that's talking it's it's affecting
everyone like I don't know if you
remember but there was a a veteran in
Staten Island we talked about this a
couple months ago where he had to be
moved out of I think it was a um um some
kind of a nursing home and they moved
him out he didn't have anywhere to go so
they could move the immigrants in the
migrants the illegals in and the same
with a hospital in Denver today 130 or
40 million dollars in debt because of
the illegals and Americans are waiting
in line for healthare forget about the
fact that the Americans have to pay for
their health care and and the illegals
don't and then we've got taking our kids
out of school so illegals can go into
the school and hotels in New York City
emptying out half of the business so we
can put illegals in look New York City
and America can no longer handle this uh
immigrant this migrant crisis and can
you imagine if Joe gets elected again
and may orcus he's being we've got
impeachment hearings the guy didn't even
show up that's how much respect they
have for
democracy self-reliance do you think
that should be a standard for admitting
new Americans as they call them well I
can bring a unique perspective because I
believe I'm the only member of the panel
as a non-american uh who has a Visa
which officially states that I'm an
alien of extraordinary ability in the
television
industry so I've always thought it's
rather quaint the way you Americans call
US aliens and we try and get into your
country but you hit on something about
is lack of knowledge about history I can
extrapolate on that because the Statute
of Liberty ironically wasn't created to
celebrate letting people into America it
was the opposite it was created to
celebrate kicking out the British and I
feel very strongly about this um because
as you rightly say the French historian
and abolitionist eduward du lub proposed
a monument to commemorate the centinary
of us independence the perseverance of
American democracy and liberation of the
nation's slaves so in fact it was
celebrating the absolute opposite of
what this clown wants us to believe the
Statue of Liberty represents it
represented America winning its
independence and democracy and the
Bedrock of any democracy is controlling
your border so he in every objective
analysis of his history is a complete
Maxi oh you really are an extraordinary
alien
here it to you ahe you think it's a bit
like it's a bit Weird Al little bit I
think you think alien you think weird
things with listen it's your language
it's the English language we took it
from you when you come to our country we
don't call you aliens we just say I'm
going to go to your country and say
you're giving me a barrage of insults
ahead just remind you you okay I'm
teasing I'm teasing you're you're a lot
less extraordinary when you keep blowing
the bre you speak English not American I
got it true hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else